and we are live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
sidre your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel
live I still can't quite get over the
fact that people are actually watching
this around the world it still blows my
freaking you guys else better to do come
on I know what
else got to do already in popcorn
power's already in Sarah's already in
Ker's already in Dave B's already in
hello everybody in the chat in the chat
how are we guys I'm doing well doing
well as well doing
good sweet it was so grammatically
correct up until
that damn it damn it I good I good do me
good me good dad um apparently I'm not
uh brain pain hey sfix guys
hey um so we're gonna be talk you can
never say his name can you it's sci-fi
Quest sci-fi what did I say s Quest I
said s Quest you said you said scix or
something I don't even think I've bother
saying that um you should know by now my
linguistic ability is somewhat limited
and my ability to get tongues round
words is B at times so just I know I've
edited a few of your
videos shots fire you're a good acronym
maker it's it's it's painful to edit
some my
videos oh God I'm dying sorry I just had
to pack of toetos really quickly before
we start it is when you get a cut and
you think that's going to be a really
good take and then you [__] you mess it
up and I cut
again it's painful it's painful it's
worse doing it it's I find it really
irritating to watch my own videos
editing my own videos it's um it's it's
it's painful I'm just the [__] to say
the go have you seen that father T
episode where um he's trying to they're
trying to do EUR rision for priests and
he's trying to just F the faking
note you w done
guys I was hoping Matthew had done but
oh it's one of the funniest things I've
seen a lot of Father's head but I don't
remember that one oh it's just they're
just there for days and he's just can't
cannot play a single note on the guitar
he's goes D just play the [__]
anyway I've sworn in the first two
minutes damn it w be banned anyway right
so we're going to be talking about
iconic remakes and things because we've
got this bloody room and then guys we
have a bit of a Stargate surprise teaser
for you which we can discuss a little
bit but first of all there's this rumor
about the
18 Night Rider The Bionic Man and uh
Airwolf being
rebooted right so it will
be all of these shows will get remade so
it'll be complete remakes of all three
shows it'll actually be Airwolf night
ride in the
18 um it'll appear on peacock in the US
I've had a little bit more information
that apparently for worldwide
distribution Netflix have have tooken
interest so we'll see it on Netflix over
here in the UK and
everything apparently Disney have
already agreed the rights to the 18 and
that's already been agreed because they
own them or 20th Century Fox do but you
know and this is all this is Gen
at a point where they're trying to find
sort of like producers and things and
they're seriously thinking about doing
this because all three shows will then
exist in
universe and will cross over with each
other think like Marvel stage one two
three sort of thing but with the a in it
instead I was thinking more like the CW
verse With The Flash and arrow that
exactly that's a better example
yeah right
so
Shar Universe it's just I can't still I
still can't decide whether this is crazy
or the greatest thing to ever happen to
me I really can't decide um I lik that
head Cannon thing you know that that guy
you interviewed the other day Mac or
something whatever his name was from the
um MCA podcast he was talking oh yeah he
was talking about MAA and Jack O'Neil
existing in the same universe because
Jack O'Neil is a twin brother and I
thought that was
brilliant that's um part of what his
podcast is he does like um
uh basically audio films sort of thing
with and that's the thing that's the
point of it but anyway um first of all
just just thr there what do you think is
is it genius or idiotic and for the
younger ones in the audience in over
here have you ever even seen these shows
do you even know what we're talking
about I have never
seen the only one I've seen is a little
bit of the
18 right um I've seen both the a teams
that's it but I don't I think I think
it's a good ide original aam and and
Liam n aam i don't that yeah so you've
never seen Night Rider you've never seen
a $6 million man do you at least know
what we're talking
about vaguely for the most part well we
can run through very quickly for the
Young no you don't have to run through
quickly oh my
God and I'm I'm having like some sort of
like seizure I think when it's just like
all three existing in the same universe
and going back and forth no we do not
need it we don't need it oh God you
don't
needam cakes but I like them there's a
reason while these young people haven't
seen it and don't know what we're
talking about they're preserving their
sanity you don't like these TV
shows I had a you know I had a $6
Million Man t-shirt back in the day it's
just we've got to move
forward yes but I the best way to look
forward is to look back no it's not have
you seen my
taxes I think I'm with you there stormy
I can't quite decide if this is
completely
moronic but I I can't help but think if
somebody does this right and we and they
C the 18 well they
cast Airwolf is still one of my
basically Airwolf is just a helicopter
with a big gun underneath and it was
stolen by a bloke called string fell who
then opened a load of nightclubs with
strippers and only Matthew understands
that reference and um he wasn't
listening there and um I didn't hear you
because because I heard myself again I
heard you twice um from my other
browser okay I was I was muting the
other browser um we've got a guy over
here that used to wear um he's he's a
bit he tried to be the the British um
like um Playboy guy um and he opened a
load of strip things and his name was
string fellow and that's the only thing
so whenever I hear like the Airwolf guy
always think of this idiot who opened a
load of rhino Spearmint Rhino was it
something in the UK anyway and string
fellow string fellow string fellow
that's so less catchy than Hugh Hefner
and anyway keep keep know so Airwolf I
know but he's he's the G string
fellow
exactly old wrinkling man um then you've
got Night Rider don't hassle the Hoff
because of the hair alone and kit that
everybody knows about Kit don't they
from ads and memes and things and
obviously The A Team they've tried to
reboot a couple of times the a team was
supposed to have a reboot in
2015 and it it came that close to
happening a TV series of proper reboot
and it came that close and
then I always thought I had seen Night
Rider um and I've been saying for years
yeah I've seen it yeah I've seen it but
I haven't the thing I I I watched when I
was a kid which I've I always got
confused with was the kman rer don't
know if you've ever heard of that no in
the UK he was called The Mask Rider and
it was the mask Rider mask it was
like yeah
mask because you're Northern
um he he was an alien I
think he had an alien like friend I
found out about him from Power Rangers
that's how I that's how I watched
it but because it the they're very
similar names I always just assumed I'd
seen Night Rider but obviously no I have
not but I know kit um from adverts and
things and I used to watch his adverts
and go I don't remember that in
[Music]
in
the rer
sorry um I live near Shrewsbury how do
you say shrewbury is it shrewbury or
shury Shrewsbury yeah that's right but
how come you say masked how do you say
garage from the south garage yeah garage
but people appear say garage sometimes
I'm like what the hell is wrong with you
people anyway look at my garage yeah but
I say bath and path and grass you say
path path and grass anyway
so Storm's having an an
aneurism could you stormy could you see
any way this could be good or do you
just think this is a horrible mistake so
so so can I just start out with Night
Rider you know if we were to remake
right night rer the storyline is going
to
be a failed Rock European rock and roll
star that's taken up crime fighting and
he's driving a Tesla
and it with a perm with a perm I mean
it's a to be electric it would have to
be electric wouldn't it well that's just
the thing I mean the Night Rider the
thing that made it cool Back 40 years
ago was the fact that it was this car
did all this fancy things you know it
talked to you it drove itself well dude
that's a Tesla Model 3 with a $7500 tax
rebate it's not a show it's a commercial
yeah but the glass on K was actually
bulletproof and we've seen that when
they Tred to do the bulletproof glass on
Teslas they break very easily he
just and smashed it remember he did that
on stage look we've got this new amazing
glass it just doesn't
break so
it's the the shell of the Cyber truck is
is is bulletproof but you know because I
think they showed like you know 9
millimeter rounds as bulletproof for the
night but anyway it's a Tesla I mean the
what Night Rider what kit was was what
we have now is is just Teslas and
they're everywhere and they're not
special and it's
boring you can obviously upgrade it
though could you it would have to be
different one thing I was wondering
whether is whether Night Rider and
Airwolf are built by the same people
with similar technology and one's
supposed to you know as part of like a
the ground attack and Air Attack and or
something so that they're related
somehow I wondered if they might do
something like that
both built by Night Industries or
something Wayne
Technologies Wayne industri that would
be better if it's Wing technology swear
to God dark Industries Batman Juju in
there everywhere one of the things about
Kit was that it wasn't armed it didn't
have
weapons would it have to now because
like you said there it's basically just
going to be a heavily armored Tesla
otherwise yeah I've got another show
that they can they can can bring into
the um into the a verse Oh Inspector
Gadget if they've got K they've got far
off actually Bic man but Inspector
Gadget what if Inspector Gadget was
driving the Matthew
brck yeah honestly that was my childhood
I would love
that
um I think Night Rider is one that is I
think I think night ride is the hardest
one to bring back for me I think Airwolf
would be really easy to bring back it's
just an armored helicopter and it would
just be cool and there's I can think of
a million ways and and The A Team having
like a a a team a military team that's
been screwed over by their government
what decade isn't that
relevant oh my God every veteran ever I
mean so that's a piece of piss to bring
back and I could see a store because
apparently the idea is to have like an
over Arch and storyline that they build
towards over a few years yeah um and I
could very easily see that it's going to
be like espar and blah blah blah and
it's because I mean the Airwolf
storyline was basically that it was a
helicopter that was built kind of I
think it was by the CIA or or no it was
a company it was something within the
CIA like a p of the CIA and string
fellow snicked it basically and they
were always trying to get it back that
was kind of the plot for Airwolf to do
the same again it's really easy it's
Night Rider that I think is a bit
outdated and and it is quite difficult
to bring back but it's such a
cool if they get it right um but like
you said it would have to be a Tesla and
that's kind of ruined it for me you've
kind of ruined it for me right these
days Teslas are much more fancy than the
original uh kit was much more fancy and
a night rider was the show out of the
three of those I like to the least to be
honest I I I didn't really watch it I
loved Airwolf every every Saturday
morning I used to build my helicopter
out of leg go and I'd play on my
helicopter and watch Airwolf um and that
was when I was like 25 years old so I
mean imagine when I was doing when was a
kid um and then I loved the 18 you know
every time I went in my shed I was
trying to like lock me in and I'll build
a tank be fine um because that's what
the 18
was but the I think of all those I think
the 18 would be probably they have the
best chances of success because 18 was
all personality driven
yeah if they cast it right yeah if they
if they cast it right I mean you know so
you know uh night rider was the fancy
car Airwolf was the fancy helicopter but
18 was all personality driven you know
and it was the tension and the
camaraderie between the uh the four
veterans and I think if anything there's
a lot more stories to tell
there than you know the the the the the
private investigator running around on
the model 3 you know it's I in all
seriousness I think that would be the
one that have the highest uh chance of
success because it's it's not all fancy
technology that kind of does never age
well but it h it has the best uh
capabilities of having great
storytelling based on these the four Li
the intersection of the four lives of
these veterans yeah I I think that's the
yeah that's the one I'm most excited
about I can't believe they brought the
18 back already to be honest I think
it's stupid when the movie failed I'm
like
TV series just do it and never quite got
the ground and particularly after like
the Iraq War and stuff I'm just like
perfect the six6 billion dollar man
though and I'm going to put a B on that
because U I think who was it just said
some would it be infected by
inflation $6 million won't get you much
in the way
of yeah so $6 billion man um they've
said that that won't come back because
they're doing a mark wallberg
movie um and they said that that that
the executives seem to have the
conversation of look let's not confuse
things with a series when we're doing
the movie Let's just bring the billion
dollar man back and jump in and out sort
of thing but I was wondering is the $
six billion dollar man though massively
overpowered to have in this series
anyway because he's super strong really
fast did you know all this thing surely
he could it's a bit like um in the
Marvel universes when you bring in a
very super powerful superhero into a you
know like a Hawkeye episode you like go
do really work um Miss Marth got and
kingpin's dead sort of thing so and
there's lots of Marvel characters that
you know apart cyborg you
know so I just think it's a character
that I think they've been very clever
there if they don't bring him back I
think it's one that's got to jump in and
out sort of thing or it's too he's too
powerful I think you know get the a team
and they're fighting the B man just
turns up and just like swats everybody
away with a flick of the wrist something
do I mean
yeah yeah it seems like people are very
burnout on um superhero kind of
stuff yeah I think so I think we need
something a bit more gritty and a bit
more realistic and I wouldn't mind if
the $6 billion doll man wasn't involved
in the stall to be honest I think the
other three is great but my main problem
with it is where the hell is Street Hawk
I just want Street Hulk to come back um
neither of you never no no clue
basically
nighte he's got laser beams he's got
freaking laser beams it was amazing and
it's actually on YouTube you can go
freaking lasers on the freaking head you
can go and watch Street Hawk on YouTube
you can watch the first two episodes and
I did when I did my back and I was in
bed for a week and it's still brilliant
but anyway
um I I think this is a brilliant idea
myself I'm leaning towards it's
brilliant if it's done right
but and I think Picard season 3 showed
us that actually people will watch
this because know bit
Nostalgia you
think I think so you know
it's I'm just reading the
syis
some
yeah yeah okay well let's move on anyway
because I just wanted to bring that up
and get to get your opinions but it's a
little bit difficult to get their
opinions if two of the people chatting
have never seen it and don't know what
the hell you're talking about but mean
thinking about it like from a producer's
point of view or an executive's point of
view it makes a lot of sense from a fan
point of view it either would make a lot
of sense or no sense at all and you
could make the argument pretty decently
either way there it just depends on what
they write I
guess yeah and it all sounds cool enough
where like hell if the Expendables 4 is
going to be the way that it is I would
much rather have this series to watch
than something like that if I want that
kind of like itch itched off you know or
or that box ticked or something like
that it sounds cool they sell a shitload
of toys oh I I mean I would watch this
not knowing as not knowing that much
about any of these things I would still
watch it if they came out with these
things just for the Intrigue
alone same yeah but yeah I just I
wouldn't know where to start they'd have
to lay it out for me kind of deal well I
think that was the other thing I was
thinking about this was they've got to
do this quite slowly because they just
build up to when they actually then do
any of the crossover events you've got
to be excited about it you've got to be
like oh my God this is so so they've got
to sort of have like a season of each
and then maybe do something where they
cross over a little bit and then they've
got to build up they've got a mar d y s
CW did CW did it with arrow Arrow first
there was like two seasons of that and
then they bought out the Flash and then
they bought out like Legends of tomorrow
and all of that and then they all sort
of started like they The Flash got
introduced in Arrow
MH um not as the flash though just just
Barry Allen which was like a teaser The
Flash is coming and then and then the
flash came out and then obviously
Millions SP after yeah like story line
is they got to tease us for a while I
liked your comparison to the CW a lot
more than like doing it like MCU like
because if they do it like MCU phase one
two3 kind of deal they have to lead to a
big bad they have to lead to something
and hell maybe the six million billion
dollar man could be one of those things
they lead to if they do something like
that but at the same time I'd rather
almost where the CW sure I I the only
crossover event I stopped watching all
of it by then was the uh the the
infinite worlds one the the good one
that you know the big
one but besides that they still did it
every year and it was like a a big event
but not like a big event that would like
destroy one of their worlds or something
like that they just all kind of join
together and found a reason to get
together some yeah I mean yeah I know
things would happen but it would be nice
if this was
more yeah yeah but but it'd be nice for
this to not be that and have it like
they don't have to have some giant world
ending thing they just have a reason to
get together instead of trying to exrate
bigger and bigger and bigger until
there's nowhere left to go that yeah
something I liked about the C what the
CW did was because all these characters
lived in different geographical
locations like Barry Allen lived in St
Central Central
City Oliver Queen lived in Star City
their stories were all contained in
their own cities until they needed to
not be it was nice yeah the Quantum Leap
reboot I think is maybe what's given
them a little bit of confidence to
wonder whether we could do it but I like
Quantum gleet because it was a
continuation it was like the next
chapter rather than a remake I think
these are all going to have to be
remakes um but Jess Marshall finish that
Quantum l I still need finish it I got
bored um so s of this happens more
realistic commun Ingenuity and not
superhero with weekly positive messages
I want the weak I want the He-man
message do you guys ever watched the end
of He-Man and they'd come on and go
don't do drugs kids and then run off
again oh was brilliant I I actually
fully agree with Jess Marshall there the
superhero weekly positive messages is
something I've really detested about the
flash you can you can do it Barry if you
just believe in the power of friendship
and run Barry run
R
of every episode thank you so much for
the super CH now I agree with I I think
superheroes I think there's a massive
fatigue with superheroes I think we're
bored of them and I think it would be
nice to see some actual real even with
Night Rider and Airwolf there's human
beings in there that are weak and
fallible and I've got these fights you
know problems to try and overcome and
you know and I just think it's a bit
more and I just want to see The A Team
shooting like crazy and nobody getting
hurt it's just like
everyone no be clever as well like they
can have a massive like problem and then
just solve it with cleverness and I
think that's that's good for TV not not
necessarily we can we can defeat them
with our superpowers just just with just
human
Ingenuity yeah that's kind like what
paperclips sorry
stor that's one thing that's one thing I
thought was um one the saying powers of
Doctor Who Is He solved the issues his
problems through being clever you know
through
Ingenuity and they're having a Sonic
Suit drive that can literally do
anything that is required by the story
as well that
helps except anything to do with wood
because he's not invented that
yet rubbish actually putting nails and
screws into a wood um but you know I I I
would agree with that that we need
something that is a bit more cerebral
and I just think I just think bring
Richard Dean Anderson out of retirement
and bring him in as mcgyver for an
episode seriously Grandad mcgyver why
not I do that I would pay him a billion
quid to do that not the new kid they've
got playing mcgyver because that was
shocking I was gonna swear but it was
shocking but bring mcgyver back think be
awesome do you guys want to talk about
gen V quickly before we do our
surprise thing what did I just type
actually as you were saying that oh my
God uh I've not seen this yet I've I've
been I forgot to watch it I will watch
this tomorrow it is to talk about any
aspect of J without we got to have a
spoiler alert
man spoiler alert then that's it GNA be
is it going to be terrible spoilers
though like big spoilers because I yeah
that just that word makes what the
episode one spoiler would be very funny
there um okay so I have just found it
though so there are three episodes out
already which is very nice that they did
that but also like there's four on here
oh my God
four I watched it this
morning and in um the first five minutes
the main character had started you know
she was 13 turn 13 had was on V and uh
started minrating her first period And
So then she killed her parents with her
minstral
blood and that's she got blood Powers
Yeah and they were activated that's how
it started that's the first five minutes
of the series and of course my wife
won't watch this show again she wouldn't
watch the piging boys with me because of
the first five minutes she definitely
watching mate I'm sorry I'm G to I'm
I've got it I've got to draw this back
in
the I Lov the boys when it first came
out I thought it was brilliant the
little fella wandering up and down the
big Willies Ure sign of put me off and I
started to think I'm not this is going
too far now and there's another little
person in this one there there's another
person that that can
shrink down yeah and not the same thing
happens with something not even similar
but similar
enough in the United States yeah
um now that what you've just told me
there about the opening five minutes of
this
episode she
can wall we're talking about it through
like in in in awe like oh my God what do
we just watch kind of point of view but
as as weird as it is to say because the
boys does do it as well
is it's well done it's very well made
very well Act very well produced is it
just it's just what you're watching is
just like holy
[__] right do you remember years ago on
the Stars Network there was um
Spartacus yeah watch that yes yes yes
and every week it was like we're gonna
have Wards brother yeah W with each
other but it was always shock Factor it
was always massive
blood sex violence and it was always
trying to chock us and that's I every
week I wented that went too far we
watching it next week of course we
bloody are and i' and I'd watch it again
the following week Julie Caesar bum
raped somebody and I still watched it
the next week
um but but the boys and gen V they tie
that I don't know what even the
grotesqueness into the story and make it
make sense like nothing happens just for
the sake of it happening it's all there
pertaining very much so to the story and
pushing things
along well but you have to IM you know
admire the creativity for a young girl
shooting her minstral blood through her
parents and through the wall and have it
make sense that is real talent that's
real talent writer over this is what we
get oh God man no I'm going into this
with some trepidation now I have ad good
I'm I'm I'm like excited as hell
now I think I think too much for
me I think that a few episodes of the
boys and it's a definitely a LoveHate
show you this is not a show you can just
watch it and go it's all right it's it's
not that you either adore it or you hate
it I just put in the common sent I loved
it but my wife hated it she want to
watch it in the background um you know
if she do just like you turn that crap
off mostly because I don't hate it I
don't hate gen V it's just holy [__]
that's how it
started honestly from the first three
episodes I I I I might like it more than
I like the first three episodes of the
boys I think the the boys is very much
more like a
a it's a better overall show probably
from what we're going to get but I I
like the youthfulness of what's going on
right now maybe it'll fade in time but I
like the youthful aspect of I'm G to
hate
that I don't think so because
it people I hate you I hate the young
people it just reminds me of better days
when my knees worked
um I hate you guys they have they have
burning crispy got a
future I've got money in the bank and a
pension he look his kids with such
disain he at the
dinner you've got such you've got future
and you're pissing turn the Xbox off I'm
streaming I do
that um they don't they ignore me they
as soon as they walk I walk out the door
they just didn't back on again
um I'm
not I was starting to lose my love with
the boys in third season I thought it
went too far I thought they had started
losing so my really yeah I I just
thought that whole um bit with the
um oh the the I forgotten the word when
lots of people get together and have sex
and I forgot the word ory the ory paloa
thing or whatever it was called I
thought that was brilliant what do you
mean people have been waiting for that
since the boys was announced that's one
of the most their most popular comic
book I know but it's I didn't like it I
it went too far it was just too much
really that was that's literally like
sneezed and grew and guys blew the guy's
dick up I'm just like well that that's
not part of the orgy but it's
also I just just to let you know what
was put to TV in the orgy was literally
like one 15th maybe 12 12th of what's in
the comic book like it was like mundane
like it was it was drawn back for TV
like nobody's business for that thing I
don't know it could crazier I think it's
a bit like horror movies to me though
like you know when you like don't see
the bad guy that's much better for me
when you just tease things and you and
you're a bit more subtle I think that's
better when it's gratuitous and on the
screen and thing I think that's when
it's it loses its appeal I think the
boys maybe towards in in towards the end
of the second season the start of the
third season because I the third season
got better um was it akles Eckles from
um yeah he's he great love that guy
about say the orgy part with not the
orgy part but at the orgy when Butcher
homelander and uh soldja boy all
together that's that's that's that's TV
right there I don't know I
just I just wish I'd um yeah I don't
know I just think it's a bit too much on
the screen and and and I got I started
to get a little bit bored of the boys
but let's see what gen V does so it's
this is the boys no no20 then in that
case b a bunch of bloody teenagers
running
around great I told you didn't I
anything with young sexy people is
whatever it is 90218 second are they
young and sexy in this I don't know
they're young so
assuming back on board okay excellent
cool wait how old are they they are of
age I know she's just come on it's all
it's all college kid yeah it's all okay
that's
fine I'm not gonna say that and then it
ends up being like some nine-year-old I
know I don't like that no no no we're
moving away from
that um we'll give it a go eh we'll give
it a go yeah right so we'll come back to
you next week and I will I'll either be
slaty going the what is wrong with you
people or I'll be like what is wrong
with me because I thought that was great
I'm gonna watch it I'm gonna watch it
after this yeah I'm gonna go watch it
after this let us know Harris uh sorry
Matthew do do you fancy running a little
teaser quickly before we you're so
pleased with this a you I am it's I've
been doing it for like the last 48
hours I've not I've never put this much
effort into a [__] sorry into like a
30 second promo oh are we not supposed
to swear
today oh no we lost that in the first
two
minutes I yeah I said I swore in the two
minutes and 33 seconds oh all
stor go on then
right
so this is a video that's coming
tomorrow this is a promo that's a video
that's coming up tomorrow this video
will go live as a short tonight as a
promo but you guys get to see it in all
its Glory so everyone be quiet MGM very
recently made contact with citrek and
they started to confirm a few little
bits of information I have now asked a
very important question and they've
answered kind of so I sent them an email
at cidre we've heard rumors for some
time that the Revival will be a
continuation but that perhaps some
changes to what we know as Stargate
would be permitted by the creators can
you reassure fans that the hard reboot
is not an
[Music]
option
um I like it like it a lot um we're
putting a bit more effort into making
the start of our videos more interesting
but that might be
actually Matt pulled that up for me
behind uh behind the scenes before we
started and I had start it over because
I couldn't contain my laughter the
second Jay turned into a lion
I messaged Jay last night when I can't
wait to show you this edit I've turned
you into a lion but not
[Laughter]
really God in heaven um if we can make
Jay Roar that would be
awesome PR's got their new 21st century
updated MGM mascot you know they're
prepared see there's a health safety guy
or if they just need
me I
mean Happy Days MGM
again hey can can I just add that um Jay
called it last week you know um that the
writer strike that the writer strike
would be over within hours and it
was I'm just just saying I have some
news on the actor strike if you
want so um one of the guys I speak to is
um he's now um he basically is a
contractor kind of and he's works for a
company that um does lights and stuff
for um a lot of sets in Hollywood and
um Vancouver and stuff he mainly Works
in Vancouver or could be a she could no
he I think it's okay to S call him he
because I'm literally talking about one
person and and he does he he's got
another job he's a manager right so it
it really doesn't matter and it I'm
pretty sure I could name him and he
wouldn't
care but I won't just in case um but
basically he said they all got back to
work this week so they have got back
into this a lot of the studios and
they're starting to set them up so a lot
of the studios were sort of like put
into like almost like moth
balls he said basically what they had to
do is they they've not like torn
anything down and a lot of the stuff
that was already
filming and um but what they did was
they sort of um
basically where they where where there
the sets they sort of put like wooden
braces in and stuff to make sure nothing
fell over and and they secured a lot of
the lighting and things to make sure
there's no fire you know they got it
they got it all just like ready just to
like sit for a bit
basically and then they've done nothing
for like three months um it said this
week they were asked to go back in and
start getting all these Studios prepped
so for me that says the studios are
expecting to get back to work very soon
um and again I was told that the studios
want everybody back to work by November
the 1st they want the stuff act for so
they must be reasonably confident that
the actors are going to obviously sagra
can still put a spanner in that and just
ABS dig their he in and refuse but it
sounds like the studios are reasonably
confident this is this is this is coming
to an end now so um and they're back
there but they are back negotiating
Monday I could see by the end of next
week will know something more I think I
think this will happen quite quickly now
and then they could back to work in a
couple weeks
please then we'll get an announcement
for
Stargate it's
[Music]
a if if that's the case do you think
they're going to announce Stargate as
quickly as possible or will they wait
for a holiday big time or something like
that something specific I guess like an
anniversary of something Stargate or
Thanksgiving or Christmas or
something the anniversary is in like
July isn't it something like that yeah I
thought it passed of sg1 yeah it's July
that was a big one as well wasn't it it
was like was it 25 years or something
yeah so when they announced the the
Ronin show and Jason MOA comes on and
talks to everybody on the SGA
anniversary what day is
that so Quest you are absolutely correct
it is a brave
new it is a brave new
um I did a poll to see what people
thought about that and um so I said now
the strikes coming to an end how long
until starget is announced realistically
the people this all their opinions
doesn't really mean anything but in the
next month 8% of people thought that
they would do it immediately Before
Christmas 34% and next year 58% and
that's at 600 votes so I think most
people are
expecting next
year I'm expecting Before Christmas h
um everything that we've said is they
were ready to announce this though they
were ready to announce the intention to
do this at San Diego ComiCon two three
months ago and they haven't stopped
working they're still building towards
it we we're still within the 25th
year like 2023 is 25 years since su1
first game so if they do it this year
they could they could like bundle that
up as 25th anniversary announcement even
though it it's like six months too late
it's still within the
same calendar year kind of
thing yeah I know what you mean um
saying that they could also go into
2024 up until July so wonder when sg1
ended oh it was like
200 N 2010
something yeah well it would be 15 years
ago would it so but um but it would have
ended the final episode was in
March
2007 that was when it was on
Sky no it would have been early in that
that was when it was on Sky one that
that was in
Britain
um no original release um July 27th 1997
to Sky won on March 13th
2007 yeah Sky must have had a deal where
they got it at the same time as everyone
else yeah so um oh I vaguely remember
staying up late to watch
it was that was that star game I can't
believe it was 2007 I was still in
school in
2007 I don't remember being in school
when it ended although I probably would
have been I mean I definitely was in
2007 but I probably would have been like
devastated yeah 20 started 1997 ended in
2007 so yeah Stargate Atlantis
anniversary started in
July so again that's no good ended in
January 2009 so that be 15 years in
January yeah that wouldn't be
shabby could do that 15 years since the
last good show of Stargate ended um
January 9th there you
go see how I did that then I was really
subtle I thought just I thought it was
stick a bit of a knife into Stargate
Universe well I don't know you said good
like not great like still good though
right come on come on it was I'm
actually digging my heels in I hate star
Universe I started watching it again you
know I keep saying that it was getting
better not sure it was I'm watching it
again I still don't like it it
definitely was um everyone just clipped
about two months ago and now now and
then clip like two weeks from now change
my mind screw you I can that's why I
said clip clip two weeks from
now you'll love it in two weeks
wildly um
but I I I don't know will they wait for
an anniversary or will they just do it
do you
think I'm kind of of the mind that they
just do it
honestly it's something that they're
excited about as a company from from
individuals that are acting in it to
people probably working and building
these sets at the moment to actual
Executives so it's it's a it's a big
array of people at the company itself
that are excited for it why why hold it
back I guess if there isn't like some
date that's like super specific to go
toss it on in the very near future we
still technically would have to wait a
whole quarter of a year before January
came along the fourth quarter of the
year just started so we'd still have to
wait three months you know might as well
get the ball rolling if they really want
to get it out by
Spring 25 or something along those lines
you know I'm just just wondering where
are there any comicons left this
year we've they they've missed they've
missed their deadlines quite quite a lot
this year for for various different
reasons so the the the anniversary
obviously is is the big one they hadn't
made up their minds at that point but
then they were fully prepared to
announce at ComiCon yeah but they
couldn't because of the strikes now the
strikes are over it doesn't make any
sense to hold back if they were prepared
to do it at that point yeah
then surely they would just they come
out the strike and then they do
it ComiCon New York comic-con's in two
weeks okay uh so that's like that's the
weekend of the 13th 14th 15th yeah 12th
to the 15th New York
so honestly we we we did briefly mention
that uh I think it was around San Diego
San Diego ComiCon either before after it
that Prime day the first Prime day of
the year was during that time and that
might be a day that they could announce
they're doing another Prime day uh or
prime two days I guess on the 13th and
the 14th if that could correlate with
New York ComicCon they could do it kind
of like maybe at a Comic Con and on
Prime day and put it out as many places
they could it could make a big deal it
being primed why not I'm just trying to
see who's at who's at who's at it
guests uh Chris Evans they could get you
McGregor to announce it
please I don't I don't care who he's
playing just put him in there's not many
that's about it I suppose because
there's no actors I suppose it's still
open there's no real actors because they
can't really talk about anything that's
the problem isn't it if they have the
actors they couldn't talk about it
anyway unless the SAG strike ends here
in the next two weeks so then if
something got announced very suddenly
sort of thing that they could all of a
sudden get a load of more people at New
York ComicCon assume New York Comic
con's a reasonably big ComicCon I
suppose you know there's a couple in
Britain that a load of Stargate people
going to there's the one in Bas and
Stoke I think it is again um or in
London there's a big comic on in a
couple of months that's before Christmas
and I know Amanda tappin and Richie inan
G I think
is um so maybe they'll do that but would
they announce it on ComiCon would would
they want to do like announce it there
or do you think they would just do it
just release a statement yes we are
doing
a movie at this point the two big ones
well la comic con's also in December so
that is an option as well so there are a
couple different places they could do it
but yeah I I I think New York Comic-Con
correlating with prime day I think Prime
day would be the perfect thing for them
they want to promote their products
their things Prime day is a big day
already all across the globe people get
a bunch of Cheaper
things hey why you're here look at this
sleeping giant of sci-fi that's awoken
and kind of put it on people's faces and
and announce a little something I don't
know uh and Robocop and a few other
things and they could got a big platform
there that they could release little
teaser things if they wanted to they
don't need to do it at Comic-Con with
with you know anybody on a stage they've
got Prime to do it and if they have that
you could have instead of two or three
four five stars on top of a stage
talking you could have literally as many
people as you want to bring back just
say like hey or just like send in a
little video just like a 3se second
video five 10 15 second video whatever
it is you could have people from all
three of the old old show cast whoever
and you could do the same with RoboCop
same with Legally Blonde it'd be more
manageable especially in the time
constraints that they've kind of been
dealt
and I think it make more sense for them
as a company
then to jump into a I mean hell New York
Comic Con I go to La Comic Con every
year for the last three or four years
but it's not like the place to announce
something I don't think New York Comic
Con would be either I think the two best
places for that would be um is it what I
don't remember what it is it cicon I
think in Las Vegas for uh like Cinema
and all all all like correlating
together or San Diego I think those
would be their two places so at this
Point give us the goodness come on yeah
if they' if they've not got a ComiCon
they can do it and actually think is
relevant like San Diego ComiCon would be
that would have been ideal they'd have
loved it but if they can't do that I
think they just yeah maybe they would
just do Amazon day and they'll just say
look this is this is what we're planning
for the next couple of years RoboCop oh
don't forget legally Bond three um
and yeah yeah most important thing
um I'd like a bit of Fan Fair but I
don't care
anything as long as they announce it
some way I'm not I'm not bothered as
long as we know 100% this is being made
yeah and what they're doing and what
they're yeah yeah and like some sort of
time frame like we're we're we're doing
this and we hoping to release by X dat
then we know and we've got something to
look forward to like it's all I want I
just want something to look forward to
and and think about the Fanfare aspect
of it honestly if they were to I mean
they could always send it to us if they
wanted to but
like take advantage of the YouTubers
take advantage of the space and the
people that have kept Stargate and
Robocop and Legally Blonde 3 alive the
people online that are constantly
talking about the things mostly the
first two of course um but the YouTube
channel we've got it you know podcast
you know there's a Legally Blond podcast
there will be I actually have a funny
story I shouldn't tell it on here but I
I'll tell you after this uh
um brain fart um but whatever that it
would be a good day to put them all
together I don't exactly remember my my
point I started thinking about my
Legally Blonde story um oh the Fanfare
aspect of it have invite YouTubers to G
give them I guess bigger YouTubers or
whoever you want to actually put it out
to tease out like this is the time we're
going to be announcing something on
Amazon day you should do live reactions
to it or something like that and promote
that kind of thing promote the um the
the the interactiveness between I
guess Amazon and it's peoples which are
kind of us you know speaking to the the
person that I speak to they've they've
sort of said we might not give you
information beforehand but we will tell
you to keep your eye on yeah that's may
just drop an email
saying keep your eyes open tomorrow
and that sort of thing and I'm like well
I'd hear anyway it doesn't really help
me it'd be better if you told me what it
was so I could do a video so I could add
the video straight out but just a
tutorium on it tell me I can't talk
about it until this time and then I
releas video but give us the press
release data or whatever yeah and you
can trust
me I
promise but I won't I won't jump the gun
um but they're not going to do that
um stormy How would how would you want
it do you care how it gets released no
it just I don't really care I mean I
don't care I mean what about how the
announcement is uh released is that what
you mean or
how yeah how do how do they announce it
do you care does it matter in the
slightest
um well I think you know if if you
announce something during ComiCon you
get a lot of eyeballs all concentrated
all at once a lot of people um
Well here here's how I say you I don't
know if you guys remember but like back
in the 60s and
70s when the new uh Cartoon Saturday
morning cartoons would start they the
networks would have a prime time
special announcing all the new cartoons
and you'd like you know watch everyone
all the kids wanted to watch this one
special because it announced all the
cartoons that was going to be playing on
Saturday for the next year and I think
comic it's kind of something like that
you know where it's all just lots of it
you know lots of information coming at
you but at the end of the day it's you
still get the shows you know and um the
way the internet is it's hard to hide
from a new announcement of anything
regardless I mean they could put it on
Twitter or X or whatever it's called
this week or Facebook or whatever and
just or or a little snippet on Instagram
and the world knows
yeah it just doesn't have a lot you know
you don't have the actors talking about
it which is you know worth a lot of
media attention etc etc but in terms of
the fans the people actually consuming
the uh stories uh we will find it I mean
look at us you know if there's any kind
of shred of gate Stargate news we we
kind of already
know I just I just noticed it whoever
put the notice the private the spoilers
I just no I'm not doing very well with
the banners today I put a banner on that
I thought was talking about M cubed for
the first 30 minutes of the video and it
meant to say that's okay what shows
that's okay um you come say howdy I
thought when they were gonna do 25th
anniversary I thought they might drop a
a like a little
documentary and you know like 25 years
just remind people how brilliant
Stargate sg1 was it's Awards and blah
blah blah and get some interviews and
stuff done again they can't can't do
that during the bloody strike because
the actors aren't even allowed I don't
get why actors aren't allowed to talk
about something they did 30 years ago um
you watch on this um I watch all these
like podcasts at the moment with his
actors and they keep having to call it
that show I did which is imagining why
okay not talk about new projects but
they can't talk about something they did
20 years ago um but I I wonder if Amazon
might be willing to do that and that's
the sort of thing you could throw
together really quickly because you
could just do a live sit down thing get
three or four of the actors cut in a few
little you know scenes from the show you
could almost do it live on on Amazon and
do it that way and it's rather than
doing like a a few actors on stage at a
ComiCon with in front of 2,000 people do
it live on Amazon Prime in front of a
billion people and do it that way just
use Amazon Prime it's what it's there
for surely um and then you could
announce it at any point but it would
would be a shame if it was just
a you know a throwaway tweet or a you
know a press release that would be a
shame for RoboCop as well I think it
deserves a bit more than that but we'll
have to wait and see but anyway so
you'll have to wait for the actual
response from Amazon it's it's
interesting but that'll be in the video
tomorrow I kind like Jamie lion if we
get a response we had a
response oh oh we know the answer was
and we're just not telling you yet so
tomorrow you will find out patreons will
find out this evening because I'll put
the video on straight after this and um
but we did get a response I just want
Jamie lion
yeah um and it's it's
a almost clear
response Matthew you've seen it
obviously would you say that's fair a
little bit
cryptic a little bit it's uh it was a
political response non committal yeah a
little bit non-committal something but
but actually no it did commit and then
sort of went but it definitely committed
it it it definitely answered the
question in a roundabout way you just
have to read between the lines a little
bit and it it opens the door
to them not doing what we want them to
do so anyway um but you'll guys you'll
find out about that um straight after
the video so
um yeah we're at the end guys this is
the end what so we do a normal little
what we've been watching this week
obviously how gen V have you seen
because I've not seen it yet oh Amazon
knows what people want thank you Carrie
social media actually does work most of
the work for
them that is mentioned and thank you
thank you so much k for the contribution
and the Super Chat really appreciate it
um
yeah guys what what you been watching
this week anything good been excited uh
so I'm all called up on uh aoka very oh
God what they've really outdone
themselves I think with
Ahsoka um store of course I started on
gen
v u one I want to go back to a couple
things um I think two shows that would
really be from the 80s that would be
good remakes would one be the Martian
Chronicle that was a miniseries so that
kind of counts I guess I think the
Martian Chronicles would be
good the other one would be and I don't
know what the status is there was like
some minations of writers being hired
writers being fired more writers being
hired but this was all kind of during Co
so Alien Nation where would he stand on
Alien Nation as a as a reboot or coming
back as it is supposed to be
still I think it's stuck in velopment
hell but yeah there was a story about it
being having a comeback um it was going
to be a straight to streaming movie I
believe I did look into it a little
while ago I'll have another look because
I've not seen anything since but I loved
alienation if you've never seen
alienation you've got go watch the movie
It's brilliant James khah is the main
guy in it but then they did a TV series
and the main actor from it um um died
recently didn't he from the TV series
the guy that actually played the alien
he he
died uh yeah I think he passed away last
year or maybe year
before um but Alien Nation was such a
clever show um it was like um Lethal
Weapon but with aliens yeah you know
like District n had that sort of feel to
it as
well um but I was brilliant I'd love I'd
love Revival it was such a good story
line such a clever story um because it
was basically like a u it was it was a
slav ship that had basically run out of
fuel and like um crashed on Earth in Los
Angeles yeah and then but then the
slaves had like overthrown the the you
know the the Masters and they like
sought refuge on in America um because
there was so many little metaphors and
things going on and um you know because
you know the metaphor for race
everything um space above and beyond is
still being talked about but it's in
such early stage of development that
it's it'll be ages until we get an
announcement I think I don't think we'll
get an announcement this year might
maybe next year but it's it's still
Disney is seriously considering bringing
back space of Bard and through Fox so
they wanted to do Firefly they couldn't
figure out to do it so somebody else
went should just basic BM me on instead
and they all went yeah okay um so that
seems to be on that conversation
went it seems to be a lot of that of
like of Executives sort of going ah [__]
it we just do something else instead it
seems to be like a lot of that but you
think that's GNA happen with our 80s
reboot put together that was the 90s
early 90s you late 90s or I'm talking
like the this the amalgamation of shows
I guess you think that'll end up going
by the wayside the same way
I'll talk about that in a sec because
let's do this Willam Moren says again
thank you so much for the Super Chat
announcements about the return of Star
as a movie or TV show are as longed for
it by fans the same way that the
Christians await the
Rapture that went dark at the
end thank you William I really
appreciate that tickle oh [__]
yeah that went dark um I don't think
this 18 thing will ever happen if I'm
honest I I don't think it'll ever happen
I think there's a lot of Executives sat
around trying to justify their
existences at the moment and I think it
possibly comes into that category I I
don't think it'll ever happen I think
it'll be such an investment from NBC to
do this at a p at a time when they don't
want to invest in anything unless
somebody very high up thinks this is a
sure thing and and thinks this is genius
um I don't think it'll happen if I'm
honest I'm kind of with you I I I just
can't see it it would it's not just I
mean investing in one show is big enough
they would be basically investing in
three over how many years and they'd be
you know they'd have to plan this out if
they do it properly they'd have to
basically have a rough idea where the
show is going to go over maybe like 10
years I just I just can't see them doing
that at the moment just can't see it I
don't think the likeliness is there for
it to be made necessarily but I really
do like the if you're going to
reboot do it in a new and creative way
that maybe intersects it with a
multitude of things instead of just like
rebooting something for the sake of it
and oh well maybe maybe we could conjoin
that with that over time and if you want
to make the universe
like pre-think it pre-think it I like
that thought process at least going into
it if they did it one of the things I
love about it is go my God it's
ambitious it's ous
plan TV um I just I just can't see it
but and the other things have we thought
up with mental and you know like with
streamer Services well it's just at a
time when all of the studios are going
we need to spend less yeah is this
really a time when an idea like this
would go but they do seem to be
exploring it so somebody must think it's
a good idea because they do seem to
explor they seem to be exploring like
can we get Netflix on board
we've got Disney to agree and they've
got as far as getting Disney to agree to
do it because they own the 18 so so
they've gone as far as doing
that it seems to be they're at least
going to a point where they're seriously
considering it so I don't know we'll see
I mean well I'm I'm I mean always use
new ideas like bring in new stuff but
they would be at an advantage with this
because they would have a baked in
audience 40 plus they're there everybody
else if if it looks cool enough you you
got all the dudes that are there just to
watch something cool immediately so it
has a baked in audience and a very large
swath of audience that would be easy to
get but it's one of those things though
isn't it like and whenever they try to
do this sort of thing if you do it wrong
you piss off just as many people really
really quickly yeah Quantum Le the
hatred towards a Le but first that had
to win people over and I think it did in
the end I think it won a lot of people
over um Les CGI yeah j's got it damn
right there and again thank you for the
Super Chat let's CGI let's have a
realistic show let's have somebody's
gonna jump over a thing don't CGI it
have them actually jumping over the
thing um that's what we want to see so I
hate I'm really get sick to death te CGI
I was watching Star Trek Discovery last
week the last season and there's loads
there's a CGI person in it this looks
like a plastic scene man and they
watching the go just just don't do that
scene it's stupid just I hate it but
well yeah what else what else you guys
been watching this week you know um I'm
up to I'm up to dat with Foundation oh
no I've got one last episode of
foundation to watch last one good
episode oh I'm really really enjoying
the second series I I sort I felt like I
had to get get through the first season
at times I felt like I F if felt a bit
of a chore just like right okay I've got
to do my I've got to do my sci-fi
homework now I'm watching the foundation
sort of thing and it felt a bit like I
had to put effort into it but the second
season I'm properly enjoying did you
also uh try uh watching second season of
Wheel of Time on
Amazon don't make me do that yeah you
gotta do it you gotta do it the last
episode you know the last episode
I caught up on all of that and The
Season's almost over with
but best episode ever I mean it was
just awesome it was it was just awesome
it tight storytelling a a lot of
tension acting is really great the
writing is much better than first season
got be better than that first episode I
sat and watched yeah yeah so second so
start it do yourself a favor second
season Wheel of Time can I skip the
first season or will I have no clue
what's going on you probably will I mean
it's you if you want have how many
episodes have you seen of season one I
thought I I watched 20 minutes of the
first
episode I really hated
it I mean it made me angry um it was
just so badly put together was it was
I'm a big fan of the books and I was
really harsh on the first season is
really disappointed but the second
season yeah and I don't go into all this
woke crap you know I don't go into this
woke crap I I I don't like it I I really
hate the ter but even I'm there sat
going this is a bit woke um okay so
women very powerful in into Magic Men
dumb asses okay I can see where this is
going and um I just uh I just couldn't
watch it but okay I how about can I get
the clip notes from the first season so
I can just watch the second sure okay so
if you could do that for me that' be
great write something up for me what
I'll do I'll just you know send you like
the good reads review
of well I tell you what I will I will
start right in the second I will just
constantly text you who's that sure
sure why is that guy hate that guy with
thing why is this woman so angry I'll
just do that okay all right I'll give it
a try I'll give it a try um it would be
nice to be able to say that I've tried
at least because that show really makes
people
angry um anything else guys before we
say
a uh I I watched a few different things
obviously Ahsoka I wasn't this as you
could see in the afterthoughts this past
week Ahsoka this last episode didn't do
what I wanted it to do I think it was
still a good episode going back and
looking at it but I was very
underwhelmed leaving it especially
leading into a
finale but I still think it's a good
episode overall um I think I told you
futur ended best episode of the season I
I hope it gets another season but I hope
it actually sticks to things like it did
in this last episode and sticks to cool
sci-fi stuff um the two things that I
have been at yesterday I started
watching Twisted Metal and I now have
two episodes left of
it it's hilarious it's fantastic it's
it's silly dumb fun but it's so much fun
and their episodes are only half an hour
long it's great it's great Anthony Mack
that's on peacock isn't it is that the
with um Anthony Mackey the Falcon
uhuh uh yeah I I've seen the adverts was
pretty cool it's so much fun it's based
off a video game I never played the
games but it makes me want
to we haven't got peacock over here so
it's got to be like somebody's got to
buy it it'd be it'd be whatever
universals on
Comcast something we've got we haven't
got anything oh damn so um uh so yeah we
just got to wait for like Sky to buy it
or somebody to get the international
rights and like end up on Netflix or
something a lot of on Netflix over here
get a VPN I'll send you my down my
login
gotta
but what everybody who enjoys sci-fi so
every every single soul that's watching
this should go do and go see is the
creator right now it's it's
rubish you didn't like it oh because i'
I've seen some people not like it and I
can understand it but coming from a
group of people that talk about like
film stuff we're people that really
enjoy like film and and I think this is
spec it can be it can come off as
mundane for your average Joe I guess
because it is very familiar it doesn't
necessarily tackle anything new but what
it tackles it tackles in a very fresh
and unique way and oh it's it's
Melancholy but it's freaking beautiful
and it's it's really well done but for a
a people that love film as a film making
aspect wise it's insane what it does on
on a shring budget on all kinds of
different things it's just it's amazing
what it does it looks phenomenal great
story please go check it out y'all I
think that's going to be um I think
that's going to be up there in the
awards ceron I think it's an instant
cult classic I don't think it'll do big
money but I think it's an instant cult
classic I think so I'll watch it right
guys thank you so much I really really
appreciate that and
um fun as always um we'll be back next
week to talk about whatever um J will
you new vid be on patreon um give me
about half
hour so I will get it on for you so it
will be on very shortly thanks again for
the super chat um is it as good as
tomorrow War oh War oh I mean tomorrow
war was God awful and looked amazing it
was a lot of fun it huh I quite enjoy
well I mean it's I enjoyed it as well
but like if you're actually thinking
about it like from a movie standpoint
the movie sucks it's it's not like a
it's not a well written even well- acted
film it's really well done in like a VFX
way and it is a lot of fun and enjoyable
to watch in like an action popcorn way
the Creator not so much action popcorn
much more it's intellectually
um are we talking about the movie with
Chris Pratt yeah the tomorrow War yes
the creators that one with John John
David Washington I almost I thought it
was a great movie I I thought the acting
was what I thought it was a great
movie I did my attention it held my
attention um expanded my curiosity you
know acting was good I don't know you're
such a hater go take a hit
I I enjoyed it they just everyone in
that thing phoned in their performances
and it's not written very well you think
it could been you think it could been
more strongly acted well I'm not saying
like it's not phoned in a bad way they
just they went to work they didn't
necessarily like bring their aame to
work they were there just it was like
another day on the office kind of deal
for all of them I think and I don't
think that's bad streaming movie there
wasn't it was done on a relatively small
budget it was done relatively quickly I
think filming was like three months so I
mean but but the post production in that
film is one of the best post- production
films like VFX wise that we've gotten
like that
would as often as we're all like well I
wish theyd do more practical than CGI
and and 99% of the time please do
tomorrow war was one of those rare
exceptions was like oh these aliens look
great their action sequences with them
look great every little bit just it fit
and work and it didn't take you out of
it which was I if they included more
butt plugs do you think it'd be a better
movie oh I mean that would have made the
acting just a little bit more um
God wrong with you people we got comment
on it a minute AG go as well if they had
Master would they have done a better job
yeah with the butt plugs yes it's right
we're done bye-bye everyone thank you
everyone in the comments everyone for
the Super Chat you absolute Legends
thank you so much um and we will be back
next week and somebody will figure out
how to mention F but
plugs gandal strikes again random even
if people just randomly shout but plugs
at the end of the video I fine whatever
a give in a give in you people want make
sure the audience is happy that's all we
want that's all we want thumb tugs say
bye-bye everybody goodbye
everybody
[Music]